han pasado aproximadamente 12 meses
desde que se instaló este campamento de
inmigrantes aquí en la frontera entre
tijuana y san diego en la zona conocida
como el chaparral se desconoce la
cantidad exacta de estas personas que
están en día y noche sufriendo con las
inclemencias del tiempo pues esperando
el tan anhelado sueño americano sin
embargo se cree que hasta el 40 o 50 por
ciento son niños son pequeñitos justo
vemos algunas imágenes de ellos desde
bebés de brazos hasta niños un poco más
grandecitos y a quienes se les está
comenzando a dar instrucción a manera de
una escuela móvil las mismas madres
centroamericanas que son maestras en sus
países de origen y bueno según césar
están apoyando estos niños para que no
pierdan su educación la noticia es
principalmente también que las
autoridades buscarán dialogar con estas
personas para que por favor ya no
lleguen debido a que ya hay muchos de
ellos se teme que exista hacinamiento y
que bueno las enfermedades lleguen
además del mal clima que ha estado
azotando la frontera por otra parte se
ha visto que se les instalarán algunas
regaderas y baños para que estas
personas puedan realizar sus necesidades
geológicas tomar un baño caliente sin
necesidad de pagar tanto lo que equivale
a 50 pesos mexicanos por día que es
prácticamente para muchos imposibles de
pagar al no tener un trabajo fijo